Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Sag mal linus willst du mir nicht mal ein paar daten spenden.
Ich habe auf jeden fall noch ein paar daten für dich tim da wirst du aber feine datenkraken kriegst du nur die besten daten von mir.
Aux
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertvierzig aufgenommen am elften april zwanzig zwanzig,
demnächst muss man wahrscheinlich sagen irgendwie seid korona so neue zeitrechnung et cetera.
In der dritten woche der quarantäne.
Ist es erst die dritte was nicht schon die vierte ich weiß nicht man verliert die zeit wochentage schwinden alles ist irgendwie so unglaublich relativ geworden so geht es allen uns natürlich
auch ja und wir sind jetzt hier mit einer neuen sendung und dieses mal sind wir nicht alleine,
der linus und ich sondern wir haben wir haben zulauf bekommen und sagen hallo julia.
Julia julia räder du warst ja schon einige male bei uns so auch heute wieder wie geht's dir wie verliebst du so deine quarantänezeit.
Mir geht es wunderbar also ich wohne ja seit neuestem wieder in berlin und habe es quasi noch so gerade vor den grenzschließungen zurück geschafft
sehr erfreulich und bin jetzt seit vier wochen mehr oder weniger in isolation und habe gerade einen baum gepflanzt.
Damit du jemanden zum reden hast.
Na wer hat das noch mal gesagt wenn man meint die welt untergeht dir dass die welt morgen untergeht da muss man einen baum pflanzen.
Wenn man meint dass sie untergeht oder damit sie nicht untergeht.
Ich glaube das soll irgendwie ironisch und tiefgründig sein.
Verstehe ironisch und tiefgründig da bist du ja hier genau richtig.
Das war super drin ja,
wir wollen mit dir natürlich über deine themen auch sprechen aber erstmal müssen wir natürlich ein paar andere traktoren hier noch vom vom feld fahren im anschluss linus die daten spende.
Ja ich habe eine schöne datenstände für dich tim.
Bei mir im verzeichnis random da kriegst du feinste daten schwer unkomplizierte,
schöne zufällige daten und weil wir ja alle in der isolation durchdrehen bin auch ich ein bisschen durchgedreht ich habe nämlich mich dazu überreden lassen ein ein format mit video zu machen.
Da wurde ich gebeten von united stream ja dass dieses konzept dieses projekt der ich glaube es ging los mit der berliner klubkultur ist aber inzwischen.
Deutschlandweit das clubs,
musik aus ihren leeren hallen streamen kann man dann eben unter united stream dot org schauen und die haben dieses programm jetzt ergänzt um content also.
Nicht musikalisch ich bin ja nicht musikalisch also ich kann ja keine musik ich kann kein kein instrument so spielen das ist jemand hören möchte deswegen.
Habe ich dort ein kleines.
Grundrechte update würde ich das mal so nennen und zwar stellt sich ja in zeiten des coronas die frage wie weit geht der staat wie weit darf der staat gehen und bei diesem.
Ausführlichen einschränkungen die wir erfahren insbesondere was jetzt hier das ausgehen angeht oder was die kontakte angeht die wir noch haben dürfen sind natürlich auch grundrechte
in berührung das am naheliegendste oder am meisten auffällig ist natürlich dass versammlungsrecht versammlungsfreiheit und da habe ich ein,
kleinen videobeitrag gemacht halbe stunde zusammen mit lea beckmann von der gf und mit ruben neugebauer von sea-watch beziehungsweise auch von der seebrücke.
Über ja grundrechte und insbesondere versammlungsfreiheit in zeiten von corona kommt und jetzt jetzt lustig weil wir die sendung ja erst am dreizehnten veröffentlichen kommt das,
gestern das das das kommt gestern um sechzehn uhr nämlich am sonntag um um sechzehn uhr,
auf united stream und wenn youtube das gefixt hat dass man längere also man muss sich irgendwie wenn man braucht ein verify account um videos die länger als fünfzehn minuten sind hochzuladen.
Der prozess für diversifikation ist aber gerade kaputt und wenn der gefixt ist dann lade ich es auch bei youtube hoch und dann verlinke ich es wahrscheinlich auch an den shownotes.
Wow das dreht sich jetzt zweimal dreimal durchs ganze zeit universum von vorne nach hinten zurück
also linus wird eine sendung gemacht haben werden die wir dann vielleicht auch schon wieder verlinkt haben sofern sie rechtzeitig aus der vergangenheit in die zukunft gekommen ist.
Ich habe ich bin gerade dabei eine sendung zu schneiden die gestern gestreamt wird.
Zurück in die zukunft sozusagen.
Zeit ist jetzt relativ geworden also nach ich glaube vier wochen quarantäne weiß ich auch nicht mehr was los ist.
Das ist tatsächlich das tatsächlich sehr anstrengend aber jetzt ist gerade das ostern bo und der hat mich ja eben das,
mit diesem ostern habe ich auch gedacht dass wir letztes wochenende schon gewesen weil ich auf meinem selbst verordneten längeren ausflügen,
auf einer fahrradtour einen typen gesehen habe der in so einem hasen kostüm,
durch über eine lehre berliner hauptstraße so marschierte da dachte ich auch cooler typ und dann dachte ich das ja auch noch gar nicht gemerkt dass ostern ist und dann habe ich die ganze zeit gedacht es wäre
ostern und wollte dann irgendwie haben
montag auch nix machen weil ja ostermontag ist und jetzt jetzt habe ich die positive überraschung ist nochmal ostern ne also.
Im home-office ist jeden montag ostermontag.
Genau.
Ostern ist ja auch wirklich der am wenigsten bestimmte termin im jahr von daher macht es auch alles nichts das kann man auch mehrfach durchleben ostern ist einfach jetzt immer.
Gerade bei den grundrechten sind ne die katholische kirche in berlin hat wollte sicher auch gegen diese gottesdienst einschränkungen zur wehr setzen.
Eine eine gruppe da war ja die die katholische kirche m fand das ja auch nicht so gut dass sie sich da so breit gemacht haben.
Genau nach kondom verbot abtreibungsverbot zölibat kinderchor haben sie sich jetzt überlegt wir wollen gottesdienst gegen corona machen naja.
Wer weiß vielleicht hätte es geholfen man weiß ja nie.
Die haben immer geholfen die katholische kirche hat immer sehr geholfen stets bemüht.
Kommen wir zu den anderen daten spenden die zu den so aufgerufen wird.
Genau da waren auch welche stets bemüht nachdem wir jetzt ja wirklich.
Inzwischen seit jahr zwei drei wochen eva contact tracing und corona apps reden und es,
sich dann langsam tatsächlich auch in der breite der,
bevölkerung so'n bisschen rumgesprochen hatte worum gehts worum geht's nicht das was ja,
muss man jetzt mal auch zugeben natürlich ein bisschen kompliziert ist so ne,
contact tracing und was tracking und achso das hilft gar nicht gegen corona ich muss sich trotzdem noch eine zu korona party gehen achso da muss ich die contact racing app ausmachen beim bei der corona party langsam alle verstanden hatten
was eine corona app ist in der öffentlichen debatte hat sich irgendjemand beim robert-koch-institut gedacht,
voll die geile idee datenspuren und hat dann eine corona app,
präsentieren lassen von dem robert koch roland roland wieder oder wieder heiß lothar ne,
lothar wieland oder wie heißt der nochmal der der robert koch.
Keine ahnung ich dachte er ist christian drosseln sagt der einzige den man kennt jetzt.
Der ist der pressesprecher oder so.
Nein das ist der der chef vom.
Der chef der chef und hat dann jetzt eine app vorgestellt die corona app daten spende und
tatsächlich haben die dann auch irgendwie bekannte von mir runtergeladen und meinten hier linus ich habe jetzt diese corona app runtergeladen voll cool aber irgendwie wo ist denn jetzt hier was mit bluetooth und mit contact tracing,
was sie nämlich da gebaut haben ist eine app die.
Auf fitnesstracker daten zugreifen soll und zwar auf fitnesstracker daten aller möglichen hersteller was weiß ich fitbit gabel apple watch etcetera p warum wollen sie das haben weil sie damit,
sie wollen quasi die vital daten haben.
Also sowas wie ruhepuls temperatur wenn die dinger das erfassen und so weiter und so fort und haben damit die hoffnung dass sie irgendwie dann auf postleitzahl ebene aufgelöst bereiche erkennen können in denen sich.
Eventuell das virus jetzt ausbreitet,
eine information die bestimmt für wissenschaftler total interessant ist für die nutzerinnen und nutzer wahrscheinlich ohne jeglichen sinn und auch im zweifelsfall auch wenn ich das sehr.
Also ich finde das ja sehr.
Beachtenswert wie die sich bemühen den leuten ernsthaft den eindruck zu verleihen dass diese daten spende app in irgendeinen vorteil oder nutzen bringen würde was natürlich nicht der fall ist das ein absoluter quatsch man hat wirklich den eindruck da gab's einfach irgendein team von wissenschaftlern das jetzt auch unbedingt noch irgendwie eine publikation brauchte.
Ja und dann haben sie halt mit heißer nadel diese app stricken lassen und zwar von einem.
Von irgendeinem startup was nämlich so eine unified für diese ganzen fitnesstracker schon gebaut hat und dieses.
Ich habe mich jetzt nur kurz ein bisschen dazu informiert dass irgendwie ein berliner helf startup in das carsten maschmeyer investiert hat ich glaube mehr braucht man auch gar nicht
wer will man auch gar nicht wissen um eine entscheidung zu treffen dann gab's noch den bericht von michael speer digital.
Kolumnist oder so würde ich sagen weitesten sinne bei der faz redakteuren kolumnist der das dann ausprobiert hat und sagt.
Er hat den ding absichtlich nur irgendwie ein fitbit zur verfügung geben und nicht seinen apple helft das ding hat aber dann auf die apple hältst daten zugegriffen.
Und offenbar wohl auch retro grad ja also es hat irgendwie erstmal so hier guck mal hältst und hat einmal alles rausgesogen.
Habe ich jetzt irgendwie gedacht naja okay komm da wird er sich verklickt haben dann hat er das halt,
also er schildert er hat es dann deaktiviert und beim hat dann nochmal geschaut und die app hat es wieder wieder aktiviert etwas was mir eigentlich nach meinem verständnis nicht möglich sein dürfte oder sein sollte.
Aber so wurde es jetzt halt geschildert und dann gab's auch nachher irgendwie eine.
Eine anerkennung von dem robert koch institut dass die sachen irgendetwas wer komisch gewesen in der rechte zuteilung und sie hätten das im update behoben komisch ja,
das datenschutz konzept bei der ganzen sache da stellt fragt sich johannes federal präsident der gesellschaft für informatik
ist irgendwie nicht geklärt werden die daten bekommt ist nicht geklärt wie lange sie dort aufbewahrt werden ist auch nicht geklärt ob man das widerrufen kann zum beispiel kann ich jetzt irgendwie meine datenspuren auch zurückbekommen,
und.
Dann hat das er sich noch in den nächsten gesetzt bei der herstellung bei der vorstellung zu sagen das sei unter einbeziehung des bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten entwickelt worden.
Und dann musste ulrich kelber eben sagen naja er hat keine fertige version der app gesehen er hätte nur im vorfeld beraten also man kann nichts dümmeres machen als das was sie da gemacht haben um,
das vertrauen einfach mal kurz sinnlos zu verspielen und die.
Diskussion die ja wirklich wichtig ist über dieses contact tracing in der gesellschaft
auch noch so wirklich schön mit anlauf kaputt zu machen und alle es gibt jetzt wirklich offenbar nicht wenige menschen die wer will es ihnen verübeln den unterschied nicht,
festgestellt haben gesehen haben irgendwie was weiß ich hier im fernsehen wird gesagt corona app ist gut ja also,
bestätigt corona app und die jetzt da irgendwie eine kleine datenspuren halt vorgenommen haben und keine ahnung haben wie sie das wieder zurück kriegen sollen.
Man fragt sich wirklich wer da was da los ist bei denen also das ist wirklich sehr traurig.
Ich finde das sehr schade wenn die da so eine an sich ja nicht ganz verkehrte idee so in den sand setzen also ich kann mich erinnern schon vor einem monat ungefähr,
er hat eine gruppe um bastian gresham sowas als open source konzept irgendwie angefangen also die idee dahinter,
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe ist dass der ruhepuls womöglich erhöht ist bevor man fieber bekommt also dass man quasi bei sich selbst,
feststellen kann dass man möglicherweise infiziert sein könnte bevor die klassischen symptome irgendwie anfangen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das irgendwie die idee dahinter ist aber ja also ich wurde auch schon von mehreren leuten gefragt corona app und da muss ich erstmal die rückfrage stellen ja welche denn.
Was natürlich nicht unbedingt,
hilfreich ist wenn man da eine große gesellschaftliche debatte braucht und irgendwie viele leute braucht die möglicherweise bei contact tracing mitmachen ich glaube aber,
das problem besteht nicht dass bei dieser app jetzt nicht viele leute mitmachen weil die brauchen ja eigentlich nur ein repräsentatives sample der bevölkerung oder hinreichend viele verschiedene leute die irgendwie solche.
Daten für eine wissenschaftliche studie bereitstellen aber die brauchen nicht irgendwie einen bestimmten anteil an der bevölkerung der das jetzt tatsächlich mitmacht mit diesen
fitbit daten also die meisten leute haben ja auch gar keinen fit.
Also wenn die sagen sie möchten auf postleitzahl ebene auflösen dann brauchen sie natürlich auch pro postleitzahlen bereich schon eine nennenswerte anzahl personen ihr amt also da,
denke ich schon dass sie da einiges brauchen und die haben es auch mit einigen pomp dann da veröffentlicht aber,
ich halte das tatsächlich für relativ aussichtslos dass diese app,
ernsthaft dir irgendwie helfen können wir zu sagen hoffe vielleicht hast du schon hier den korona du hast in letzter zeit ein bisschen erhöhten ruhepuls das halte ich für relativ unwahrscheinlich dass sie das auf diese ebene bekommen und.
Das ist auch glaube ich gar nicht geplant also das ist dieses andere open source projekt quantifiziert flo die sich damit beschäftigen aber ich glaube die die robert koch-instituts app.
Die gibt tatsächlich einfach nur daten ans und man kriegt überhaupt keine nachrichten zurück also insofern ich glaube die nutzer in selbst haben da jetzt keinen direkt.
Nutzen von.
Ne das ist also deswegen haben sie es ja auch so genannt obwohl ich den namen auch extrem unglücklich finde ja also wenn sie jetzt irgendwie sowas was weiß ich dass deutschland thermometer oder sonst irgend so ein dusseligen namen auf den sie sonst immer so gerne
das hätte schon sehr viel besser gepasst weil das sozusagen sie wollen da halt so ihren ihren big data fühler reinhalten ins land und das halte ich eigentlich auch für gar keine schlechte idee
nur wie schon gesagt hat das timing ist halt einfach mehr als bekloppt und man merkt einfach dass sie mit solchen sachen relativ wenig erfahrung haben.
Also ich habe zwei prothesen zu der entstehung a irgend irgendjemand beim robert koch institut der oder die.
Von sonst nicht viel sonst nicht viel schnitten abbekommen hat von dem corona braucht auch noch eine veröffentlichung und hat gesagt wir machen mal hier so 'ne.
Von mir aus in deutschland thermometer ich finde das super deutschland thermometer finde ich gut weil dann kann man auch immer regelmäßig gucken ob deutschland wieder fieber hat.
Und das finde ich gut.
Und die andere hypothese ist da mir klar relativ bekannt ist das ist eine ganze menge leute gibt und start-ups und hast du nicht gesehen die alle meinen sie könnten irgendwie etwas beitragen kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen dass diese leute,
da einfach aufgetreten sind neben hundertachtzig anderen und gesagt haben guck mal was wir können so oder so sehr unglücklich.
Aber auch im bereich des kontext tracing gab es,
ja eine nennenswerte entwicklung ich habe sie in der heiße show noch angekündigt ich hab's noch prophezeit ich weiß nicht mehr ob ich das letzte mal hier in der im logbuch auch schon gesagt habe,
dass ich davon ausging oder ausgehe dass apple und google sich relativ,
bald in diese diskussion einmischen würden der grund warum ich davon ausgegangen bin,
ist dass es auf beiden eben auf beiden plattformen probleme gibt in der implementierung die sage ich mal vereinfacht werden können wenn das betriebssystem mitspielt.
Und b dass ich zumindest bei apple ja sehr die tendenz sehe dass sie.
Ja sich so als als deine gesundheit
ding darstellen irgendwie so deine uhr sagt die stimme auf hast du lange gesessen atme mal wieder ein bisschen ne und heute hast du dich nicht
bewegt mach mal hier noch ein bisschen an christian und roten ring voll sonst kriegst du keinen award und so ne und schon so ein bisschen mit den methoden des nothing zumindest sicher sehr in so einem
helfe ebene bringen wollen und deswegen,
hätte ich es für naheliegend dass sie sich im zweifelsfall auch bei dieser leider der.
Größeren krisen der menschheit die im gesundheitsbereich liegen sicherlich auch irgendwie ein schönen namen machen wollen und.
Das ist dann jetzt auch zumindest,
geschehen in einem jahr kurzen moment vor am oster donnerstag glaube ich relativ spät abends,
relativ am nachmittag die hölle dann zu deutsche zeit zumindest die hölle zu und es gab einen eine technical spezifikation.
Mit sowohl apple und google logo obendrauf das hat's glaube ich vorher noch nicht gegeben oder.
So in der form nicht nee.
Kann sein dass das irgendwo aber dass sie wirklich so sagen hier wir haben uns zusammengetan.
Und es gibt natürlich vorteile wenn du in dem betriebssystem bist du kannst es seit den,
vollständigen zugang ohne limitationen auf die hardware potenziell du kannst die verbreitung natürlich sehr viel besser regeln sie können.
Auf den sicherheitsstandard hinarbeiten und sie können vielleicht auch eine form von kontrolle ausüben weil sie zumindest in der ersten phase sagen sie wollen eine bereitstellen,
auf die dann eben ausgewählte contact tracing apps zugreifen können und da wollen sie mit den,
gesundheitsbehörden der länder oder der staaten dann eben zusammenarbeiten und da auch so ein bisschen
offenbar sagen so ja wir wir gehen hier auf euch zu wir helfen euch dabei aber vielleicht auch nicht allen ja damit ihr nicht so viel scharlatane entsteht das sind
erstmal die ganzen positiven aspekte auch das was sie da als standard für bluetooth und als standard für die kryptographie beschrieben haben.
Macht erstmal nicht den absolut wahnsinnigen eindruck die haben glaube ich schon die debatte sehr genau verfolgt die da in den in der akademia stattgefunden hat.
Darüber wie man so etwas bauen kann aber insgesamt sind das noch relativ wenige seiten,
das sieht erstmal okay aus aber es reicht nicht zur finalen bewertung denn wie ich schon oft gesagt habe bei sowas steckt der teufel im detail und dieses dokument ist einfach nicht detailliert genug um,
wirklich dann am ende die architektur und die implementierung.
Tatsächlich zu beurteilen grundsätzlich muss man natürlich auch immer
wenn irgendwie apple und google im raum sind eine gesunde portion argwohn walten lassen und
es ist jetzt tatsächlich bei diesem informationsstand einfach noch nicht zu beurteilen ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist ja es sieht jetzt gut aus und jetzt kommt es auf die details an und das
betone ich nur deshalb weil ich natürlich auch eine reihe an anfragen dazu bekommen habe die alle gerne irgendwie einen daumen hoch oder einen daumen runter,
haben wollten und das ist leider an diesem zu diesem zeitpunkt jetzt noch nicht möglich.
Ja das ding ist ja relativ neu und wenn ich es richtig sehe haben die auch vor zwei wochen damit angefangen sich da zusammenzusetzen also wir haben da quasi so eine taskforce gebildet
von
experten wahrscheinlich aus allen möglichen bereichen bluetooth auf der einen seite krypto etcetera und keine ahnung wenn sie da noch mit reingeworfen haben und das ist jetzt erstmal das papier und ich denke sie wollten zu diesem zeitpunkt auch erst mal klar machen.
Wir arbeiten da an was sie haben ja auch gesagt das kommt auch erst im mai.
Ja aber wir haben uns hier mal eine abi überlegt und wir haben mal dass das funktionsprinzip was wir uns vorstellen man dokumentiert und jetzt geht's wahrscheinlich eine globale feedbackrunde um zu gucken,
ob sie denn wirklich auch an alles gedacht haben und ob sie da nicht noch noch nachbessern müssen.
Also dieses kommt im mai ist natürlich schon mal dass das eines der auffälligsten probleme weil so wie die das formulieren ist es eher am ende mai und oder mitte mai.
Und das.
Wäre natürlich schön wenn's früher käme da gibt's glaube ich projekte die sich früher bereit sehen.
Sehen hier schon ein lounge anzustreben und die sich jetzt natürlich auch auf die füße getreten fühlen könnten.
Aber müssen nicht erst flächendeckende tests da sein damit das überhaupt geht weil also wenn man jetzt irgendwie symptome hat aber sich tagelang nicht testen lassen kann dann geht doch wahrscheinlich auch contact racing nicht oder.
Nein die sache ist ja die du kannst dich ja testen lassen wenn du einen anlass dafür hast ja und.
Die der gedanke wäre ja dass eine alarmierung durch eine solche app tatsächlich auch eine ein anlass dann für dich wäre die andere perspektive ist tatsächlich und das ist natürlich auch der teil warum man.
Warum es vielleicht zweifel geben kann dass apple und google das so in der form perfekt,
hinkriegen je nachdem wie sie es jetzt ausgestalten wäre er durchaus zum beispiel so dass man sagt okay
du brauchst dich gar nicht testen zu lassen weil wenn du im april irgendeine art von oder im mai in dem fall oder der juni irgendeine art von erkältungssymptomen hast gibt's relativ wenige.
Verdachtsmomente was du da hast ja sodass man auch unter umständen je nach lage im lande die entscheidung treffen könnte okay wir setzen das kriterium runter man muss gar nicht getestet werden.
Man kann auch einfach symptome zeigen.
Dann wäre es doch aber wahrscheinlich sehr leicht für irgendwelche trolle das system zu stören oder also wenn man sich nicht testen lassen muss und einfach sagen kann hier ich bin infiziert das wäre wahrscheinlich nicht so schlau.
Das ist genau richtig oder ist eben eines der probleme und deswegen
jetzt gibt es ja eben auch tausende details die da eben eine rolle bei spielen können ne also der punkt
okay du wurdest getestet oder von mir aus auch von einer ärztin geprüft dass du diese symptome zeigst das gibt's ja alles in in abstufungen und was da der richtige weg ist,
spielt glaube ich eine große rolle auch jeweils vor dem vor der epidemiologische lage in dem land.
Den gesetzlichen regelungen in dem land und.
Auf dieser basis kann dann eben eine eine sinnvolle oder weniger sinnvolle entscheidung getroffen werden und das ist da eben alles noch nicht so drin die haben jetzt erstmal nur eine spezifikation für okay wenn jemand
diagnostiziert ist dann kann er andere leute waren und diese teures systems ist da in der form bei denen noch nicht im scope.
Also vielleicht ist sie im skoda aber das was sie bisher veröffentlicht haben ist ja auch wirklich nur ein protokoll,
unterbau ja es ist sozusagen nur eine vereinheitlichung bestrebung wie die tatsächliche kommunikation laufen soll und welche daten durch die welt gefunkt werden das wollen sie ins betriebssystem packen was.
Wie schon angedeutet im prinzip 'ne sehr gute idee ist aus vielen gründen wird könnte vor allem zu einer globalen vereinheitlichung führen aber sie lassen ja explizit
offen,
wie eine meldung tatsächlich in ein system kommt an welche server diese daten weitergeleitet werden etcetera das ist dann immer noch die aufgabe einer oder mehrerer
apps und wie dieses regime dann konkret funktioniert dass es wahrscheinlich genau das was,
jetzt wo jetzt die diskussion beginnt und wo man mal schauen muss wie sich das in den nächsten wochen entwickelt gerade weil es eben mit vielen fragezeichen verbunden ist aber,
sicherlich ist es so wie du sagst julia dass gerade diese teure resistenz natürlich ganz ganz wichtiger punkt ist dabei es muss in irgendeiner form eine.
Eine eine eine erlaubnis als eine art absegnung einer solchen meldung geben das war ja auch schon bei diesem p t
teil davon da wurde damit so tanz das ganze angedacht wie es dann konkret kommen wird müssen wir jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt noch nicht,
ist aber auf jeden fall ein zeichen dass diese debatte jetzt global entbrannt ist.
Ja dann haben wir ja mit julia eine urheberrechtsexperten hier bei uns und können uns endlich dem urheberrecht widmen.
Überhaupt der einzige grund weshalb hier bin.
Ein jahr eu copyright director ist jetzt bald oder hast du.
Ja ja.
Mir gerade noch gesteckt das heißt der albtraum ist jetzt schon ein jahr alt.
Am siebzehnten april ist quasi das offizielle jubiläum der urheberrechtsrichtlinie ich habe auch schon presse anfragen gekommen zu bekommen,
mit der frage warum ist denn das internet immer noch nicht kaputt wobei man sich da ja darüber streiten kann also die urheberrechtsrichtlinie ist ein jahr alt aber sie ist noch nicht in deutschland in nationales recht umgesetzt also das heißt,
das jubiläum ist jetzt quasi das jubiläum der verabschiedung durch die eu,
aber deutschland hat noch zeit bis juni zweitausendeinundzwanzig um das ganze auch in deutsches recht umzusetzen.
Ok das heißt was sagst du denn dann.
Also das ist jetzt eine ganz,
dumme situation eigentlich weil auf der einen seite gerade das thema artikel siebzehn uploadfilter da ist man ja froh wenn man jetzt noch ein bisschen gnadenfrist hat
bevor das ganze in nationales recht umgesetzt wird aber auf der anderen seite werden natürlich in anderen ländern jetzt fakten geschaffen,
also frankreich ist schon fast davor seine version von artikel siebzehn,
zu verabschieden das ist jetzt irgendwie für mai auf der tagesordnung und ja die machen halt also die reine lehre uploadfilter für alles.
Deutschland hat sich da ja noch ein bisschen rum gedrückt da gab's diese protokollerklärung wo drin stand wir wollen uploadfilter möglichst vermeiden,
wenn deutschland jetzt keinen vorschlag macht und das sehr lange raus schiebt dann ist natürlich zu befürchten dass sich andere länder in der eu eher an dem französischen ansatz
orientieren werden das heißt also ich ich sitze jetzt fast auf glühenden kohlen und warte darauf dass die bundesregierung etwas vorlegt dazu,
damit ich es dann kritisieren kann aber bisher haben sie ja nur.
Also einen referentenentwurf zum leistungsschutzrecht irgendwie letzte woche auf ihrer website veröffentlicht aber den dann kurz später auch wieder runter genommen und gesagt also das war ein fehler und er sollte eigentlich noch gar nicht online gehen
also das heißt über die offiziellen vorschläge der bundesregierung zum urheberrecht sind wir immer noch im dunkeln.
Wie wie wie wie stellen die was auf ihre website und dann schnell wieder runter also das schnell wieder runter frage ich mich.
Also so schnell war es gar nicht also es war so am ersten april vermute ich haben sie einen referentenentwurf veröffentlicht also das ist quasi die offizielle der offizielle vorschlag der bundesregierung der geht dann ans parlament wird beraten und so weiter.
Und
also da stand ein referentenentwurf datiert auf den ersten april auf der seite des justizministeriums zur umsetzung vom leistungsschutzrecht da stand drin also bis acht wörter darf man irgendwie verwenden und mehr nicht,
was wirklich also ein großes problem darstellt also die sagen in ihrer eigenen
gesetzesbegründung irgendwie der durchschnittliche satz in einem presseartikel ist irgendwie zwanzig wörter lang und da sollten dann irgendwie ausschnitte von acht wörtern genug sein aber gut
ja und ich habe den erst am freitag entdeckt also zwei tage später irgendwie am dritten april was sowieso ungewöhnlich ist weil normalerweise wenn,
die regierung so einen gesetzesentwurf veröffentlicht dann verschickt die den sofort auch an verbände,
gibt möglicherweise in pressestatement ab nichts davon ist passiert also habe ich mich erst mal gewundert und hab dann darüber getwittert wie bescheuert das ist mit den acht wörtern,
und ein paar stunden später war der vorschlag wieder weg.
Und dann gab es irgendwie ich glaube ein paar tage später noch ein statement von,
justizministerium das sei ein büro fehler gewesen ich finde büro fehler ist ein sehr schönes deutsches wort.
Das heißt du hast du hast diesen referentenentwurf einfach weg getwittert.
Also ich will mir da selbst gar nicht so viel einfluss zu sprechen aber vielleicht haben sie gesehen julia findet ihr nicht gut da gehen wir vielleicht lieber nochmal drüber.
So haben wir uns das mal vorgestellt julia.
Ich glaube den eindruck haben viele beim twittern dass dass ich die welt.
Ist das bei dir bei dir nicht so linus also ich habe schon so viel so viel elend aus der welt geschafft indem ich das einfach auf twitter kommentiert habe.
Auf twitter nochmal erklärt habe warum das falsch ist nein natürlich kommt julia da wahrscheinlich in der bewertung bisschen mehr.
Ohr zu als wenn ich was twitter.
Aber glaubst du glaubst du tatsächlich dass an diese geschichte es ist im büro fehler also es kommt mir so ein bisschen.
Also ich glaube.
Es fast schon weil einfach so dieses heimlich still und leise referentenentwurf veröffentlichen ohne den an die verbände zu verschicken das ist einfach nicht der weg wie das normalerweise passiert.
Man muss ja auch dran denken also wahrscheinlich sitzen die auch gerade alle im homeoffice und vielleicht funktionieren die normalen arbeitswege nicht so gut wie sonst dass ich mir schon vorstellen kann dass es ein fehler war.
Ich finde bloß also so diese diese zweite büro fehler das ist immer so wie wenn ursula von der leyen sagt diesen,
anstößige tweet den hat die praktikantin verfasst oder so das finde ich einfach vom stil her doof also ich finde irgendwie die leitung von einem,
politischen also von einer institution oder einem ministerium die muss schon gerade stehen für die fehler die sie macht und so dieses jahr das war das büro oder das war die praktikantin oder so das finde ich einfach naja,
würde ich so nicht machen.
Vielleicht wenn du wenn du angst hast dass wir da irgendwelche teenager auf der straße sind und sah darauf hinweisen dass sie keine bots sind aber ja also du hast schon recht dass wir wer wer komisch.
Wollen wir mal ein anderes thema ansprechen was wir hier auch schon ein paar mal hatten in den letzten wochen nämlich diese ganze geschichte mit knie.
Genau julia kann das kann das copyright nicht auch mal für uns sein.
Also.
So lese ich das mit dem mit dem copyright gegen clean view vielleicht war das mit dem copyright gar nicht so eine schlechte idee.
Ja dann lass uns kurz nochmal wachrufen worum's geht clever ist diese ominöse unternehmung die einfach auf social media sozusagen an allen orten wo es sich ihnen anbot ja,
gesichts,
fotos eingesammelt hat portraits fotos von menschen und die dann eben identitäten zugeordnet hat sodass man darauf auch eine wunderbare gesichtserkennung machen kann und das ganze als dienstleistungen an wer auch immer genug bietet
ja angeboten hat und es wurde auch freudig on the world angenommen und verschiedenste institutionen und behörden auch
haben sich aus diesem pool bereits bedient aber jetzt.
Ärger und es gibt die einschätzung dass man da gegebenenfalls mit dem tollen urheberrecht gegen vorgehen kann ist das so.
Du hörst mich laut seufzen,
also ich habe ja ein paar monate in amerika verbracht am bergman klein und da habe ich diese idee auch gehört
ich dachte das liegt einfach daran dass die amerikaner halt kein vernünftiges datenschutzrecht haben und denen deshalb gar nichts anderes übrig bleibt als irgendwie sachfremde gebiete zu nehmen wie das urheberrecht,
um gegen diese letzten endes persönlichkeitsrechte verletzungen vorzugehen dass man einfach irgendjemandes foto nimmt und das für gesichtserkennung,
verwendet also dass das was clever gemacht hat nach der datenschutzgrundverordnung illegal ist es glaube ich relativ klar.
Und insofern wundert mich diese diskussion ein bisschen in deutschland und also ich halte es für sehr gefährlich das urheberrecht für solche dinge heranzuziehen also es fängt schon damit an das rein logisch ja die geschädigte person,
die person ist die auf dem foto drauf ist also die deren gesicht ohne zustimmung scannt wurde und nicht
die person die das foto gemacht hat die aber urheber ist und.
Insofern also glaube ich sowieso dass also selbst wenn das geht wüsste ich nicht warum.
Man das machen sollte außer dass man halt irgendwie grundsätzlich gegen cabrio ist.
Die andere sache ist die dass das urheberrecht werke schützt also künstlerisch wertvolle werke in irgendeiner form und es ist in deutschland sowieso ein problem,
dass es ein leistungsschutzrecht gibt das wirklich jegliche fotos also egal ob sie irgendeinen künstlerischen gehalt haben oder nicht,
schützt den sogenannten lichtbild schutz und das führt in der praxis zu ganz vielen problemen weil.
Also so grundproblem urheberrecht und digitale technologie ist das,
ist kein register aller urheberrechtlich geschützten werke gibt keine datenbank wo man irgendwie nachgucken könnte ist das jetzt ein inhalt den ich verwenden darf oder nicht.
Gleichzeitig aber alle digitale technologie kopiervorlage achte also eine kopie ist etwas was beim weber recht grundsätzlich eine erlaubnis braucht und das ist einfach wenn es um solche dinge wie scraper geht
nicht besonders sinnvoll,
vielleicht ein ganz einfaches beispiel ein bekannter von mir der hat einen cochlea-implantat das ist irgendwie ein.
Digitales hörgerät dass ein analoges signal.
Aufnimmt und in ein digitales signal umwandelt also ein kopiervorlagen,
und das ist irgendwie in seinen kopf implantiert genau wie das funktioniert weiß ich jetzt nicht aber jedenfalls ist kopiert und deshalb kann der hören und das würde jetzt bedeuten also wenn jeglicher kopier vorgang,
der rein technisch ist irgendwie eine urheberrechtsverletzungen darstellen würde dann bräuchte der eine erlaubnis um sich musik anzuhören was natürlich unsinnig ist,
also genauso halte ich es für relativ unsinnig,
das reine kopieren von daten wo es wirklich darum geht daten auszuwerten also es ist ja clever egal
ob das foto künstlerisch wertvoll ist oder was genau da drauf ist sondern eigentlich geht es ja bei gesichtserkennung um proportionen zwischen unterschiedlichen teilen des gesichts und so weiter und nicht darum,
wie jetzt irgendwie das gesicht ausgeleuchtet ist was für einen eindruck die person macht oder so.
Und das ist einfach nichts wofür das urheberrecht gedacht ist und geeignet ist und wenn man das so weit ausweitet dass man sagt also urheberrechtlich geschützt sind einfach daten.
Dann hat man ganz andere probleme also dann ist so gut wie alles was wir irgendwie im internet machen letzten endes eine verletzung von urheberrechten und genau aus diesem grund,
weil das unsinnig ist ist sogar ein teil der neuen e urheberrechtsrichtlinie die ausnahme für text and data mining die sogar sagt dass wenn man nicht explizit irgendwie per robots textil oder dergleichen,
der daten.
Dem scrolling oder der datenanalyse widersprochen hat dann ist dieses daten- mining keine urheberrechtsverletzungen das heißt selbst wenn man jetzt.
Vielleicht klagen könnte auf basis des deutschen urheberrechts ist das etwas was der gesetzgeber auf eu-ebene eigentlich für falsch hält und beschlossen hat mit wirkung zu juni nächsten jahres dass es nicht mehr möglich sein soll.
Tja also ja okay.
Rand ende ich kann doch ich kann noch weiter renten aber ich glaube einfach datenschutzgrundverordnung ist die richtige basis um dagegen vorzugehen nicht das urheberrecht.
Jetzt hast du ja auch eine neue aufgabe du bist jetzt bei einer organisation angedockt die wir hier auch schon öfter mal beleuchtet haben bei der gfa.
Gesellschaft für freiheit.
Freiheitsrechte genau und was machst du denn da jetzt ist das schon so hast du da schon angefangen ja du bist schon voll im saft ne.
Ja also ich bin jetzt in berlin ich hatte eigentlich gedacht ich würde im zdf büro sitzen jetzt sitze ich im homeoffice aber ja also ich bin jetzt bei der gfa und leite dort das neue projekt control copyright
bei control copyright geht es darum dass das urheberrecht an ganz vielen stellen mit den kommunikationsfreudige seiten in konflikt gerät
kommunikationsfähigkeit im grundgesetz ist irgendwie artikel fünf das ist meinungsfreiheit informationsfreiheit zensur verbot,
kunst-und wissenschaftsfremde zeit so im wesentlichen.
Und die gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte wie ja wahrscheinlich die meisten mitbekommen haben macht strategische verfahren vor gericht.
Also die idee bei mir warum ich mich jetzt mit strategischer klage führung zum urheberrecht beschäftigen möchte.
Die kamen auf auch so ein bisschen als lehre aus der eu-urheberrechts debatte wo naja trotz großer proteste irgendwie,
diese absurden upload-filter beschlossen wurden.
Das eigentlich grundrechts basierte warnungen größtenteils ignoriert wurden also zum beispiel der un sonderberichterstatter für meinungsfreiheit david hat,
vor dieser reform oder konkret vor artikel siebzehn gewarnt es gab viele wissenschaftliche statements die sagen,
das verstößt gegen die grundrechte zuletzt,
gab es eine studie für die grünen bundestagsfraktion von professor spintler die das nochmal festgestellt hat und.
Naja die bundesregierung wird das jetzt aber umsetzen müssen weil sie dafür gestimmt hat ist es jetzt verpflichtend und.
Ich glaube es gibt durchaus einen gewissen umsetzung spielraum diese probleme.
Na ja zumindest abzumildern aber ich gehe schwer davon aus dass am ende was auch immer rauskommt bei der umsetzung von artikel siebzehn ist zur sperrung von legalen inhalten kommen wird und das ist einfach eine ganz massive,
einschränkungen der meinungs- und informationsfreiheit ich glaube uploadfilter sind.
Prinzipiell technisch nicht in der lage die entscheidungen zu treffen die eigentlich für urheberrecht,
fragen notwendig sind also solang irgendwie der uploadfilter keinen sinn für humor entwickelt wird der eine legale parodie nicht von einer urheberrechtsverletzung unterscheiden können,
und da kommt auch noch mal dieses problem ins spiel dass man ja gar nicht sicher weiß wer eigentlich der rechte inhaber ist weil es ja kein register gibt.
Also oft ist es einfach so dass irgendein großes medienunternehmen einfach behauptet der rechte inhaber zu sein und die plattform sperren dann halt.
Und wenn artikel siebzehn dann umgesetzt ist.
Muss der aber trotzdem den anforderungen des grundgesetzes und der eu grundrechtecharta genügen und mit diesem projekt control see oder control copyright wird die gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte eben jetzt.
Mit mir zusammen klagen zu urheberrechtliche fragen vorbereiten also artikel siebzehn ist auch nicht das einzige thema,
es gibt jetzt auch im zuge von korona glaube ich viele,
urheberrechts probleme die irgendwie ganz offensichtlich werden also ich habe mal geschaut zum beispiel achtzig prozent aller wissenschaftlicher studien die sich mit beatmungsgeräte befassen sind hinter einer paypal,
obwohl wahrscheinlich der großteil von denen öffentlich finanziert wird also es gibt noch andere punkte wo auch das heute schon geltende urheberrecht,
sicherlich grundrechte welche probleme schafft und das bekommen im moment vor allen dingen glaube ich die lehrerinnen und lehrer die universitäten die bibliotheken zu spüren die irgendwie von heute auf morgen ihr gesamtes,
tätigkeitsfeld ins internet übertragen müssen,
aber oftmals funktioniert das überhaupt nicht mit dem urheberrecht also zum beispiel bei bibliotheken wird halt gesagt also ja kindern vorlesen in den eigentlichen räumlichkeiten das darfst du,
aber wenn du das per livestream machen willst das ist nicht erlaubt was du aber dürftest ist irgendwie.
Das auf video aufzuzeichnen und dann auf einem speziell dafür eingerichteten computer in den räumlichkeiten der bibliothek.
Anzubieten und dann kann eine person mit einem usb-stick in die bibliothek kommen,
und kann sich eine kopie von dem video auf ihren usb-stick ziehen und mit nach hause nehmen das wäre dann wieder erlaubt also offensichtlich an vielen stellen relativ problematisch.
Insofern also ist auch meine hoffnung und mein aufruf leute also wenn ihr in eurer.
Arbeitswelt in eurem alltag solche.
Grundrechts fragen habt die sich irgendwie am urheberrecht aufhängen sich bei mir und bei der gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte zu melden,
wir beschäftigen uns jetzt eben auch nochmal vertieft mit der kommunikationsfähigkeit und mit diesem spannungsfeld kommunikation urheberrecht und medien.
Das heißt ihr seid jetzt schon konkret an ein paar klagen dran.
Nein also ich fange jetzt wirklich an also wir gehen quasi heute mit diesem projekt live und es ist auch jetzt quasi mein.
Erster arbeitsmontag hat bei der gfa also das ist ganz frisch ich habe,
für unterstützung bekommen von der shuttle foundation das ist eine stiftung die meine arbeit fördert die sich,
mit freier software und open open open culture und so weiter beschäftigt und wir fangen jetzt gerade damit an.
Ich habe mir das auch so von der reihenfolge der schritte ein bisschen bei max schrems angeschaut der hat ja auch,
seine zu klagen um die datenschutzgrundverordnung,
ein jahr bevor die datenschutzgrundverordnung überhaupt in kraft getreten ist gegründet weil solche dinge einfach einen gewissen vorlauf brauchen also man muss ja erstmal.
Überhaupt leute informieren dass sie sich mit diesen fragen jetzt an die gfa enden können,
wir müssen ein gewisses finanzielles polster aufbauen um solche klagen auch wirklich durchführen zu können,
der beste weg um das zu machen ist einfach fördermitglied bei der gf zu werden alle diese dinge wollen gut vorbereitet sein und unser ziel ist eben auch dass wir von tag eins
wo jetzt die deutsche umsetzung vielleicht in einem jahr von artikel siebzehn in kraft ist wie auch in der lage sind solche klagen anzustoßen.
Und das heißt das richtet sich jetzt sozusagen auch an eine bestimmte,
öffentlichkeit kannst du nochmal sagen was,
also von wem würdest du dir denn jetzt primär erstmal abgesehen jetzt von spenden
oder fördermitglied schaften von von wem würdest du dir denn jetzt vor allem erstmal feedback versprechen also das sozusagen
leute die jetzt tief im urheberrecht drin stecken oder eher so betroffener also kannst du mir mal erzählen was du meinst wie er sich das so abspielen wird.
Also betroffene können durchaus urheber innen und urheber selbst sein also es ist ja oft auch bei diesen problemen rund um die uploadfilter so das letzten endes inhalte gesperrt werden die eigentlich das original sind,
irgendjemand anders dann irgendwie als sein eigenes ausgegeben hat oder so also das heißt auch die kommunikationsfähigkeit von urlauberinnen und urhebern selber ist betroffen an vielen stellen,
es gibt auch einige regelungen im deutschen urheberrecht die eigentlich ganz positiv sind.
Die aber wenig praktisch genutzt werden das heißt ich wäre auch interessiert an.
Anfragen oder kontakt von leuten die diese möglichkeiten vielleicht nutzen wollen also beispielsweise es gibt im deutschen urheberrecht einen zweiten recht für wissenschaftliche publikationen,
das heißt wenn du irgendwie eine studie verfasst hast und du musstest dir aus welchen gründen auch immer bei silvia oder so publizieren also bei einem.
Wissenschafts verlag wo die sachen hinter der power landen dann hast du nach dem deutschen urheberrecht ein jahr nach veröffentlichung das recht das zwei zu veröffentlichen und zwar dann kostenfrei ohne paypal und so weiter.
Es wird aus verschiedenen gründen von sehr sehr wenigen leuten gemacht,
weil einfach auch viel rechtsunsicherheit darüber besteht also was genau man da eigentlich darf also da sind,
einige relativ komplizierte dinge die in diesem gesetz drin stehen zum beispiel dass man die akzeptierte manuskript version nur veröffentlichen darf und ich fände es also auch interessant leute die solche dinge.
Ausprobieren möchten aber vielleicht das rechtliche risiko,
nicht einschätzen können oder ihnen das zu groß ist die das nicht tragen können dass sie sich an mich wenden das können nutzerinnen und nutzer sein es können weberin und urheber sein,
ich führe einen regen austausch mit vielen so.
Urheberrechtlich an verschiedenen unis und so weiter.
Und bin dann natürlich auch immer dran interessiert also was so die bremsen fragen sind sicherlich also der ganze bereich bibliotheken.
Ist jetzt vor allen dingen in zeiten von corona und wo die alles ins internet umstellen müssen auch ein sehr interessanter bereich also da bin ich auch für hinweise dankbar,
und letzten endes die ganzen social media influencer die.
Sich auch ja sehr rege an der debatte um artikel siebzehn beteiligt haben.
Ich hoffe auch also dass die wenn sie sich vielleicht von den klassischen,
urheber- verbänden nicht so gut vertreten fühlen aber doch solche probleme sehen also zum beispiel copyright striktes bekommen von denen sie nicht so recht wissen was das jetzt eigentlich soll dass die sich auch mit solchen fragen an mich wenden.
Also schon eher so unmittelbar betroffene leute.
Ich meine die g f die macht das so die hat ihre eigenen,
intern juristischen kräfte wir stellen auch gerade jemanden ein konkret für diesen bereich urhebern medienrecht.
Ansonsten kriege ich da auch relativ viel unterstützung und beratung aus der wissenschaft also die betroffenen das ist glaube ich für den staat,
sinnvoll damit wir halt so ein mapping machen können was sind so die großen fragen die möglicherweise.
Grund rechtlich geklärt werden müssen also es ist auch nicht so dass es da wenig fälle gäbe gerade.
Ich war etwas traurig letzte woche hätte eigentlich der bundesgerichtshof in drei grundrechte fragen zum urheberrecht entscheidungen präsentieren sollen und das ist jetzt ausgefallen ich nehme mal an weil die auch im homeoffice sind,
das war unter anderem diese geschichte mit moses pelham gegen kraftwerk wo es um die remix kunst geht also sicherlich ein super wichtiges,
thema für die kunstfreiheit darf man irgendwie kurze ausschnitte für sample verwenden.
Und dann gab es noch zwei fälle wo es im grunde genommen um die pressefreiheit gegen also um die frage darf man zum beispiel staatliche dokumente veröffentlichen als.
Zeitung was glaube ich für die pressefreiheit super wichtig ist also ich könnte mir auch solche fälle vorstellen da hat halt die bundesregierung mit verweis auf das urheberrecht versucht,
informationen über den afghanistan krieg zu unterdrücken in dem fall.
Was ist deine also ich meine ich könnte mir jetzt mal vorstellen so stellt sich mir das jetzt zumindest da.
Ihr geht jetzt erstmal in so eine sammlung phase rein es geht also an die öffentlichkeit sagt ja hier kontroll-ct gibt's jetzt sprecht uns an
und dann wird's erstmal so eine zeit geben wo ihr quasi feedback einsammelt mit leuten in kontakt tretet etcetera
um dann irgendwann zu sagen hier dieser bereich zeichnet sich ab da ist eine menge
zu holen im sinne von da gibt es viel interesse da gibt es viele leute die quasi mitgehen würden sie mal die frage wer klagt denn dann eigentlich müsste es mal immer die
sein oder also muss man da sozusagen bis zu einer gewissen klage bereitschaft da dahin gehen oder reicht es wenn man euch nur fälle und konstellationen schildert die muss ja ja dann letzten endes irgendwann auch zu die entscheidung fällen okay
das ist jetzt hier die stoßrichtung da wollen wir reingehen da lohnt es sich jetzt anführungsstrichen auch wirklich mal ein fass aufzumachen.
Also der regelfall ist schon dass die gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte betroffenen unterstützung gibt also das kann entweder sein dass die,
zum beispiel verfassungsbeschwerde einreichen gegen ein bestimmtes gesetz oder dass sie selber verklagt wurden von jemandem oder selber,
vor gericht stehen das ist der regelfall also dass die gesellschaft für freiheitsrechte dann fälle unterstützt von betroffenen die in irgendeiner form an die g f herangetreten sind,
es gibt einige andere möglichkeiten also zum beispiel ist es jetzt so bei artikel siebzehn konkret dass.
Eine ganz normale person wie du und ich jetzt zum beispiel nicht,
unmittelbar zum europäischen gerichtshof zum eugh gehen könnte und sagen könnte,
ich halte dieses gesetz für unvereinbar mit den grundrechten es ist so dass bei solchen eu-richtlinien ein mitgliedsstaat,
eine anrufen des eugh wirken kann und das hat in dem fall polen auch gemacht bezüglich nur zwei absätzen von artikel siebzehn und da steht die entscheidung noch aus,
aber das wäre jetzt kein keine möglichkeit die der gf so offen steht also das heißt die normalen.
Fälle sind dann tatsächlich so dass betroffene die entweder.
Sich gedanken darüber machen ob sie eine klage bereitschaft haben die möglicherweise sogar schon abgemahnt wurden oder verklagt wurden oder,
dergleichen sich an die g f wenden.
Okay das macht man an wie.
Also info at freiheitsrechte punkt org,
also auf der webseite findet man die informationen über control copyright unter freiheitsrechte punkt org slash urheberrecht.
Also auch wenn man sich jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher ist ob ein,
ein bestimmtes urheberrechtliche des problem dass man habt ob das jetzt grundrechte relevant ist oder nicht oder ob man überhaupt einen rechtsweg hat,
kann man sich auch damit eben an uns wenden und schauen ob das vielleicht ein interessantes thema ist es ist natürlich auch klar also strategische prozessführung heißt also dass die gfk die ja einen verein ist,
als solcher,
mitgliedsbeitrag finanziert natürlich nicht alle fälle annehmen kann mit den leute so an uns herantreten sondern es geht wirklich darum,
fälle auszuwählen,
die eine besondere grundrechte und strategische bedeutung haben und wo man auch denkt also das hilft jetzt nicht nur dieser person sondern,
das hilft eine grundsätzliche juristische frage zu klären die auch für die zukunft von bedeutung ist und wo wir alle was von haben.
Also für mich sind hier primär eigentlich zwei fragen offen julia die erste frage wer hat verdammt nochmal die idee gehabt für diesen genialen namen weil so ein ding kontroll-ct zu nennen ist,
gut sehr gut.
Das freut mich natürlich kreatives brainstorming um ein uhr morgens das war möglicherweise ich.
Hammer nee wirklich genial also weil für die also natürlich nur das kopfhörer hier kontrollieren dann das copyright logo drin kontrolliert aber natürlich kontroll-ct ist einfach der befehl zum,
beenden der meisten prozesse wenn sie sich noch freiwillig beenden lassen und das ist sehr schön
sehr sehr schön gewählt kann ich kann ich nicht anders sagen und die zweite frage die geht natürlich auch dann direkt ans eingemachte moses pelham.
Gegen kraftwerk bist du team pelham oder team kraftwerk weil das ist ja schwierig zu entscheiden wenn man möchte eigentlich man möchte eigentlich,
appell im recht bekommt aber man möchte das natürlich eigentlich nicht.
Offenbart genau,
die wichtigkeit von strategischen klagen also es ist zum beispiel sehr wichtig dass auch die klage führende partei irgendwie oder die partei die versucht bestimmte grundrechte geltend zu machen.
Sympathisch ist und anschlussfähiges und dass sie ein gutes beispiel ist für den punkt den man machen will und der punkt den man denke ich machen will ist.
Wenn man sendling nicht erlaubt dann illegalisiert man damit im grunde genommen eine ganze kultur form.
Also hip-hop lebt davon dass man sich eben in form von samples mit anderen werken auseinandersetzt.
Und wenn das nicht geht ja also das ist so ein sehr geschlossenes bild von kultur wo mal wieder eine.
Ja eine kultur form die letzten endes von unten kommt die von marginalisierten gruppen kommt dann einfach in die illegalität gedrängt wird und das wäre natürlich extrem schade.
Das dann ausgerechnet moses pelham und sabrina setlur die standard träger für dieses extrem wichtige thema sind ist ein bisschen schade.
Ich bin aber in diesem fall dann tatsächlich so leid es mir tut team denn der punkt den sie da wachen ist völlig richtig und also ich finde es,
dramatisch auch das kraftwerk letztenendes diesen prozess seit zwanzig jahren durchzieht und versucht.
Irgendwie da da recht zu bekommen also auch kraftwerk sollte ja irgendwie ein interesse an einer verteidigung der kunstfreiheit haben sollte man meinen.
Tja so ist das mit diesen alten heron irgendwann.
Die haben auch glaube ich seit ungefähr zwanzig jahren nichts mehr publiziert oder.
Ja ich weiß es nicht.
Könnte vielleicht damit zusammenhängen.
Nichts brandneues zumindest.
Aber es ist natürlich schon etwas tragisch und ich glaube also man sieht es auch beim eugh das unsympathischer fälle,
meistens nicht zu besonders sinnvollen entscheidungen führen also es gibt zum beispiel eine ganze reihe von urteilen wo der eugh mehr oder weniger webseiten betreiber für.
Den inhalt der links auf ihren webseiten verantwortlich macht.
Und die sind halt teilweise durch ja relativ zwielichtige klage parteien zustande gekommen.
Das finde ich sehr schade weil letzten endes war das dann vielleicht für die richter in diesem einen fall plausibel.
Aber ist nicht unbedingt im sinne der allgemeinheit und man stellt sich auch die frage also wie ein webseiten betreiber letztenendes.
Einen überblick darüber behalten soll was alles auf seiten passiert dir verlinkt hat und ob da möglicherweise irgendwo eine urheberrechtsverletzung passiert.
Brother sage ich dazu nur.
Das ist nämlich der uhr der ursache die basis des des break beats am.
Sozusagen der beste claudia betrieben wurde
ja julia das ist 'ne tolle sache finde ich also freut mich auch auch sehr dass du da mit deinem hintergrund und und deiner deinem spezifischen vor training was so im bereich urheberrecht ja jetzt auf eu-ebene hat es da mit der gf zusammenkommt
passt eigentlich ganz gut oder.
Ich freue mich sehr drauf also irgendwie die gfk ist ja auch relativ schnell in den letzten jahren so aus dem nichts zu einer glaube ich,
sehr renommierten und sehr erfolgreichen ngo in diesem bereich zu herangewachsen,
ja ich hätte natürlich jetzt meinen eigenen verein gründen können aber dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich zwei jahre mit satzungen schreiben und gemeinnützigkeit beantragen und so weiter beschäftigt und ich möchte eigentlich viel lieber.
Wirklich am urheberrecht dranbleiben und ich glaube das sind super kompetente partner die ich da gefunden habe und ich freue mich auf jeden fall sehr auf die neue aufgabe.
Ich denke da kann man die auch nur erfolg wünschen oder.
Das tun wir auf jeden fall.
Das tun wir werden jetzt extra also jetzt kann man es ja sagen aber,
wir haben noch nie irgendwie gesagt dass wir bei logbuch netzpolitik die sendung nicht sofort veröffentlichen wenn tim die endlich fertig geschnitten hat ja und.
Vereinfacht dass das schneiden jetzt noch so vierundzwanzig stunden dauert dann tut es gar nicht so wie es tut mir jetzt natürlich furchtbar leid um deinen stream.
Der dann ja jetzt auch mit einer neuen gf kollegin ist aber ja die ankündigung habe ich jetzt natürlich vermasselt.
Ich habe gehofft dass ich dass ich hier vielleicht noch ein paar streamen zuschauer für passt stream zuschauerinnen werben kann wenn ich.
Videoschnitt kann ich dir ganz ehrlich sagen wie du schnitt das das will man nicht also das ist auf jeden fall schwieriger als audio schneiden tim.
Also klar.
Deshalb mache ich immer nur ich mache immer nur so zwei minuten videos die man auf twitter veröffentlichen kann das ist da weniger arbeit.
Ja das scheint mir echt ja vielleicht kriegen wir das auch hin also ist vielleicht vielleicht schaffe ich glaube wir müssen eh dann beim bei den nächsten united gestream kürzer kürzere episoden abgab liefern und.
Läuft dann eigentlich auch technisch im hintergrund oder.
Nee quatsch also.
Eigentlich wollte.
Dj lidos.
Eigentlich wollte ich nämlich linus auflegen und bis dahin gelaufen und hat gesagt ey die ganzen geilen djs und so ich bin doch auch ein geiler dj oder so ne du erzählst mal ja was über grundrechte linus von musik verstehst du nix.
Ich gebe zu dass ich zwischenzeitlich also als die e-mail kam und gefragt wurde ob ich nicht auf was.
Wollte ich schon dachte so ja klar also ich will.
Dass sie auf mich aufmerksam geworden seid so ich kann gerne kommt ihr hier zur könnt ihr sehen wie ich hier die musik produziere und so ne aber ja ne wand leider nicht so gemeint.
Wäre deinen durchbruch geworden.
Absolut ja endlich mal nicht nur oft auf kongress und camp veranstaltungen auflegen sondern auch mal mit den großen aber.
Aber ohne versammlungsfreiheit ist ja auch nichts mit den clubs.
Wichtiges thema ich habe gehört sie haben auch also die polizei in berlin hat ein autokorso aufgelöst das fand ich merkwürdig.
Dass man sich im auto anstecken kann finde ich.
Aber gottesdienste in autokino abhalten ja ja das ist doch.
Why not.
Ja eben da kann man auch autokorso machen ist ja letztlich genau das gleiche autokorso im autokino.
Man hat auf jeden fall wir haben hier eine reihe an sehr erstaunlichen auslegungen dieser,
kontakt sperren beziehungsweise auflagen manche nennen sie ausgeh-verbote oder wie auch immer dieser regelung besprochen und da ist natürlich da ist natürlich einiges los ne also die,
demonstrationen darunter jetzt leiden zu lassen ist denke ich ein zustand den man in keiner form so halten kann der weder im interesse oder weder im sinne der.
Dieser verordnungen ist noch irgendwie haltbar also und das aber es geht natürlich dann.
Geht natürlich dann los also wenn die polizei,
die polizei ist wahrscheinlich auch zufrieden dass sie jetzt irgendwie hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt ist leute einfach so zu ärgern ohne dass sie jetzt irgendwie was nennenswertes zu tun hat und sobald sich irgendwie zwei leute,
zusammenstellen dann einfach als polizist da hinzugehen und mit denen einfach stress anzufangen hast du wahrscheinlich zu anderen zeiten in berlin andere arbeitstage gehabt und,
wenn sie dann mal schon so eine schöne verordnung in der hand haben wo sie jetzt auch noch mal so richtig den demonstrationen in die suppe spucken können.
Dann ist natürlich klar dass da allerhand missbrauch der lage stattfindet und den muss man natürlich entgegenwirken.
Ja also ich finde das auch sehr schwierig also je länger letzten endes auch diese auflagen andauern desto schwerer wird's zurechtfertigen dass im grunde genommen im moment ja.
Gar keine versammlung zugelassen werden also das ist dann auch für die demokratie irgendwie nicht auf dauer hinnehmbar.
Immerhin.
Ich bin ich habe heute eine längere zeit auf einer parkbank gesessen also dreimal die polizei vorbeigefahren aber er hat sich nicht groß dran gestoßen also ich glaube das wird sich jetzt auch alles einrenken man muss glaube ich auch allen stellen zu gut erhalten
dass sie sich kollektiv mit uns in einer situation befinden die so keiner vorher gesehen hat und dann die bei uns jetzt alle erstmal gewöhnen müssen und das
manche teile erstmal überreagieren das ist sicherlich auch klar trotzdem im bereich demonstrationen muss ich das natürlich recht schnell verbessern weil ich habe irgendwie so den eindruck es gibt,
immer noch demonstrations bedarf.
Es gibt demonstrations bedarf.
Auf jeden fall.
Also moria ist immer noch da.
Auch darüber haben wir gesprochen deswegen war natürlich oder das war natürlich mit ruben dann das thema aber jetzt sicher nicht meine ganze sendung spoiler.
Kommen wir vom hundertstel aufs tausend.
Auch also wichtiges thema ich finde es schon spannend irgendwie vierzigtausend erntehelfer können eingeflogen werden aber fünfzehn kinder aus griechenland nach deutschland zu bringen ist irgendwie ein großer logistischer aufwand aber okay.
Wir können ja gar nicht spoilern weil deine deine sendung war ja gestern schon und das ist ja schon alter scheiße ist so alt ich weiß gar nicht warum du das überhaupt noch aufbringst hier,
julia vielen vielen dank dass du dazu gestoßen bist.
Ja danke euch es ist ja schön mal wieder mit menschen zu reden hier.
Endlich mal richtig.
In berlin trifft man nicht so viele.
Naja ich bin am stadtrand.
Dann haben wir's oder hast du noch was linus.
Ja ich möchte aber ich möchte noch danken ja und zwar das war wirklich eine sehr erstaunliche erfahrung und zwar habe ich mich entschieden dass ich hier,
wenn wir hier so jetzt immer fern podcast dass ich gerne ein neues audio-interface haben möchte und dann habe ich dieses audio-interface,
auf meine wunschliste gemacht aber das ist kein besonders
günstiges audio-interface deswegen bin ich nicht davon ausgegangen dass wir das jemand schenken würde also wenn ich dann irgendwann habe ich gedacht ach komm jetzt kaufst du dir mein audio-interface und bin auf die seite des anbieters gegangen.
Und habe die dieses audiointerface geklickt.
Und ich war so mit dem bestellvorgang so gerade fertig so ich weiß nicht mal ob ich schon also ich hatte gerade oft bestellen ja ich möchte euch geld geben geklickt da klingelt es an der tür.
Und des amazon männchen steht da und drückt mir dieses audiointerface in die hand und ich habe erst mal so gedacht,
ich habe mich wirklich so am kopf gekratzt und dachte so das kann doch überhaupt nicht sein ja das ausgepackt und hat dann in dieser helm hat er jetzt vor der tür gewartet und so dann dachte irgendwie schon so an qualityland und so und dann viel aber zu dem audio-interface noch ein zettelchen raus,
nämlich von der mir das geschenkt hat und gesundheit und liebe grüße ausrichtet und das hat mich sehr gefreut.
Super sam day delivery ist so jetzt gibt's so sehen moment delivery.
Ja deshalb ich deshalb auch sehr gefreut einen lieben dank auch für deinen server dieser bringt mich und die family wieder im wohnzimmer zusammen ach mensch.
Und deswegen genau das interface hatte heute seinen seinen jungferde flug quasi.
Super nochmal vielen dank an dich julia vielen dank fürs zuhören das war's tschüss bis bald.
Viel erfolg julia bis bald tschau tschau.
Aux